we asked kosovo having been in a similar
position many years ago feel the pain of
these people we understand that they are
looking for safe haven just because they
must no one leaves their home because
they they want to they are leaving
because of the persecution because of
the terror that they are facing so we
feel that pain and for that reason we
want to do everything in our hands in
order to support their arrival to this
safe haven in this case in kosovo um i
have to to say that for us
looking at these horrendous images of
people going into the airplanes and and
trying to escape uh is really bringing
back lots of very painful memories so
everyone in kosovo is really feeling it
and for us this is primarily a moral
obligation at the same time we want to
join the international efforts to uh
make sure that we do everything we can
with regards to this human tragedy
when will you be ready to receive the
first refugees and do you have any idea
when they will actually arrive as you
say it's a very dire situation at the
airport
we're already ready to to receive the
first refugees what we're doing right
now is increasing capacities so that we
can receive more uh for that reason i
cannot mention the final number until
the studying of each and every location
in kosovo that can host them is not done
and it's just a matter of days but we're
already ready to receive the first group
so it will depend of course on how their
transportation is arranged because it's
arranged by the united states and we're
in touch on daily basis with the us
government on this issue so you don't
know when the first ones are going to
start arriving uh we will know probably
by the end of this week because um
there are of course lots of
complications that are arising
in the issue of arranging their
transportation is not as simple as it
looks and it's not like these people can
just leave for example while arranging
the
evacuation of our own kosovo citizens
from kabul it took days to arrange that
evacuation it's not like it can happen
just like that so uh i'm sure that it's
a matter of days until we get to know
when the first group is coming but as i
said what is important is that we are
ready with an open door and with an open
heart
are all your citizens out of kabul that
you know
i'm sorry and once again are your
citizens out of kabul that you know of
yes uh there were five citizens that got
in touch with the ministry of foreign
affairs we worked together with the mfa
from day one and we've managed to
evacuate them obviously there are
emergency numbers out there if there is
anyone else that would like to be
evacuated we worked hand-in-hand with
our uk and u.s partners also to make
sure that our citizens are evacuated
there was a very small number right now
in the past there were many working from
kosovo uh citizens from kosovo working
with uk forces and u.s forces in
afghanistan but most of them evacuated
last year or in the past couple of
months so it was only these five
citizens
that got in touch with us to help with
their evacuation and that is done right
now
you say this is a moral issue um do you
plan to offer any of these afghan
refugees settle status in your country
as i said the the discussions that we've
had with the u.s
was related to people employees that
worked with the u.s institutions for the
us army who already expressed interest
to go directly to the united states but
because their application is taking time
we will be hosting them for that time
as long as it takes uh here in kosovo we
haven't received any requests for people
to come here but as i said we have an
open door policy and most importantly
there's no country in the world that
understands the pain of refugees more
than we do
do you think that we are going to soon
see the images we saw back in 2015 when
we saw
waves of refugees walking across the
european continent
it will it will really depend on the
situation and the circumstances in
afghanistan i do hope that
the pictures of persecution that we're
seeing especially against people that
really fought for democracy for
protection of human rights will stop and
i do hope that the international
community will not just stay idle but
will try to help in this regard so that
the basic human rights of the people of
afghanistan are protected uh obviously
if this doesn't happen we might see
those scenes in the future so that's why
we cannot just stand and watch uh what's
happening but we have to use every
diplomatic or other means in order to
stop violation of human rights in that
country